I think that talking about it like it's
a normal technology and not something
smarter than you is basically misguided
and having The Wrong conversation so
it's not even in the right category of
the stuff Postman talked about it's not
electricity right it's not nuclear power
it's not nuclear weapons it's not even a
super virus it's something that has its
own plans
you don't get to just plan how to use it
it is planning how to use itself
so a totally different Paradigm needs to
be applied here I mean imagine if
somebody was like well we're about to
contact these aliens with much more
advanced technology that think faster
than us that are smarter than us that
have been around the stars for a while
they're Landing we're not quite sure
exactly when we're not sure how fast
their you know spaceships are you know
it might be two years it might be 30
years and somebody is like well you know
this is just like electricity right
let's use the cool stuff about their
technology but make sure they don't do
anything bad right it would be silly to
say it in that way precisely